welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the guy that
always sticks to his guns when it comes
to fake leaks and we have a lot to talk
about this episode so you may have seen
some DC fandom leaked circulating online
in regards to the upcoming event these
apparently detailed the ins and outs of
the entire convention and they quickly
picked up a lot of attention because of
what they had in them now throughout
this video we're gonna be breaking down
what the leak said and then what James
Gunn publicly posted on Twitter in
regards to them I'm not gonna even
bother with a spoiler warning because
they're not real but if you enjoyed the
video then please drop a thumbs up and
make sure you subscribe to the channel
for videos like this every day without
the way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into our breakdown of the fake
DC phantom leaks okay so the leaks which
were posted to subreddit DCE leaks
yesterday said the following all of this
is from a legitimate source which
obviously we know it's not but let's
first start off with the movies and HBO
max projects which will be announced at
DC fandom a first-look teaser trailer
for matt reeves is the batman movie
which gives us a first look at Catwoman
the Riddler and Batman in their suits
we'll already seen Batman in his suit so
not much of a first look a new trailer
for Wonder Woman 1984 which will give us
a first look at kristin wigs cheetah
casting announcement an official release
day for Aquaman - James ones involvement
as director and writer will be confirmed
yah-ha Abdullah teen and Randall Park to
return as Black Manta and dr. Steven
Shin respectively in the sequel the
first official trailer for James Gunn's
the Suicide Squad showing off the entire
cast casting announcements for Black
Adam movie and plot synopsis casting
announcements and plot synopsis fishes
am - David F Samberg returning to direct
casting announcements for the flash
movie biggest one being Michael Keaton
reprising his role as Bruce Wayne /
Batman this is - officially established
the DC Multiverse on the big screen
which was introduced on the CW's crisis
on Infinite Earths crossover event the
movie is more a multiverse film than
flashpoint though it draws inspiration
from the latter official trailer for
Zack Snyder's Justice League showing off
never-before-seen footage so people know
this is a completely different film
Steppenwolf's original scary look from
Batman V Superman will be in this movie
and featured in the trailer official
announcement of David Ayer's cut of
Suicide Squad it's coming for sure
whether the announcement is at DC fandom
or not is yet to be decided
so how do they know that they have these
leaks inside that if this is the
official event but they don't know yet
anyway however it'll release after Zack
Snyder's Justice League yet we already
knew that the studio has dubbed this
project as AO wolf
stupid unlike the site of the a occur
does not require any additional
photography since it's completely shot
just need to work of the FX which is
happening right now highly doubtful as
David Ayer hasn't said that publicly and
he's kind of said you know we would love
a tavern but it might happen now details
and casting announcements regarding HBR
Max's Justice League dark series take
this next sentence alone with a grain of
salt which means it's made up probably
there are unconfirmed rumors of Keanu
Reeves reprising his role as John
Constantine right okay a cyborg project
starring Ray Fisher is Victor stone is
in the works for HBO max whether it will
be announced that fandom or not is
unconfirmed again they don't know
official announcement regarding the
return of Ben Affleck is Batman for a
batfleck project on HBO max athlet will
return with his original script for the
Batman movie he was supposed to star in
featuring giome Angelenos Deathstroke
and Jared Leto's Joker
the last point talks about the secret
movies one of them Satana and the other
one is Batman Beyond which we'll see now
we won't see cuz we know it's not know
okay so lots of information there but
James Gunn came out not long after this
and tweeted the following sorry to
hamper anyone's excitement but this
isn't real
yikes so you would think that that would
be the end of it with a pretty much
shutting down the rumor but the person
who posted it then said well what which
part isn't real now as my Home Slice
Johnny MP said it doesn't matter it's
from an unreliable source and therefore
we can take this as being completely
made-up and untrue Gunn did clarify that
it seemed like someone was pretty much
making educated guesses but on the whole
most of the things on it were made up
from this we can take that it's the much
more outlandish claims that were made on
the list
rather than the ones such as trailers
and footage which we do know will be
there now over the last week I've had a
lot of backlash over saying that don't
think Ben Affleck will be coming back to
the DCU as I'm the only one reporting on
it and because of this people haven't
subscribed to me thumbs down the video
and said that I'm being too negative and
that contracts have been signed it kind
of sucks because I've always tried to be
as credible as possible here and
whenever I posted fake leaks I've always
come out and said on the next video that
they were wrong which is something that
I did on my Michael Keaton announcement
video after discussing a fake script
that I'd been sent the reason I always
call out clickbait is because it makes
my job ten times harder due to the
amount of people that don't there's a
large number of websites and youtubers
that instantly take things that they
read on the Internet as fact and even if
they know they're untrue they still
report on them as they know they will
get clicks this story is a prime example
of that
we had a poster admitting that they were
a teenager in India but because they
said they had a legitimate source people
believed it straight away without first
questioning why a kid in India would
have inside knowledge - one of the most
highly secure and high-profile events in
DC history the fact there's so many
youtubers and websites out there making
stuff up just for views makes my job
more difficult because there's just so
much distrust when a group of people are
happy to spread lies because it will get
them more revenue my channel is popular
but it's rare that I get millions upon
millions of views on a video because I
often approach things skeptically I
could easily get far more views than I
do by just making things up however in
the long run it ruins your channel for
example I used to visit we got this
covered almost hourly and now I never go
back there because it's just so much
fake stuff as an example when a story
comes from The Hollywood Reporter you
trust it because they don't tend to make
stuff up and we've seen that for years
when it comes from we got this covered
you don't trust it because they do make
stuff up I guarantee that in the run-up
to endgame we got this covered had more
visits to their endgame post and The
Hollywood Reporter did but now we know
what was fake and what wasn't we've got
this covered have shot themselves in the
foot whereas The Hollywood Reporter
haven't
if you want long-term success you can't
have short-term goals and think of
things in the here-and-now
I want to do this job for a long long
time and I'm not going to last very long
if people think I'm lying to them so
though I might sound negative when I say
that I don't believe certain rumors are
true it's because I've been around the
block enough times to know when stuff is
made up I'm not someone that will drink
the kool-aid because a kid on reddit so
they have a legitimate source in the
industry now I'm reporting on this
because it's rare for people like James
Gunn who actually have legitimate
connections to come out and debunk this
stuff I would say that some of the stuff
on the list will probably turn out to be
true such as the trailers and costume
looks however the more extreme things
I'm skeptical over and you should be too
let's be real when I'm reporting on
stuff I'm not telling you that stuff
isn't true to try and trick you in fact
I'm doing the opposite and now you may
be mad that someone you love told you
one thing whilst I told you the opposite
one of us is getting frowned upon in the
short-term whilst the other isn't
now people post this kind of stuff
because they know that people's memories
are short and by the time the event
actually comes around so many other
rumors will have happened that you won't
remember who will have posted what and
who won't have again I'm very skeptical
over the whole ben affleck thing even
more now because the main point in the
tweet was that Affleck was the thing
listed as the big homerun in this the
fact that Affleck has said he's not
coming back gun has now said it's untrue
and so much more really makes me think
this entire thing is just a rumor that's
gotten out of hand
but people have been happy to report on
it because it brings in clicks again I'm
not telling you this because it will
make me popular in fact it's probably
the opposite and at the moment I'm
pretty much going in a different
direction to everyone else and saying
that it's untrue this probably won't
make me a fun channel to watch because
no one likes to be told things are wrong
and they think that they aren't I would
love to see Ben Affleck back as at the
moment he's my favorite live-action
depiction of the character but after the
hell that he's gone through over the
last couple of years it's actually nice
to see him happy with Anna D Armas this
was a guy that almost ruined his life
over being Batman and now I feel like
Alfred sat in the cafe watching him
finally smiling and I don't want it
ruined for the
now there are other notable things on
this list that of course seem fake to
but we shouldn't have to wait until the
directors of these franchises come out
and shut them down you have enough
common sense to know when something is
sensationally being sell to you and if
it sounds too good to be true then it
often is I would love to be proven wrong
but I don't want to drink the kool-aid
because someone on the internet said so
from now on if you see a rumor making
the rounds and it's not being reported
on things like the big trades and that's
probably because they're aware of it and
know it's untrue they like money just as
much as the other websites but they know
that in the long run they'll ruin their
reputations if they report on things
that aren't true so it's best to be
skeptical over this kind of stuff really
feel like I probably ruin your day with
this this kind of rant but I'm sick of
seeing this stuff circulate over and
over especially when it's clearly made
up now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the news and if you still
hate me or not
and now some of you watching this will
still be saying well he said some of it
might be true and we'll grasp at straws
but I don't know how much clearer this
can be made so I am sorry and I love you
but look James Gooden said it's not true
and remember every month we give away
free movies to people I subscribe to the
channel
this Monday go on the MCU infinity saga
box set and all you have to do is
comment on a video and make sure you
subscribe with notifications on the
winners gonna be chosen at random on the
15th of July and the Celt be shipped out
from then to ever gets the prize you're
gonna support the channel from as little
as a 99 cents a month then please click
the join button below
we massively appreciate you and as a
thank you you get access to content
early gonna come chat us after the show
either follow us at heavy spoilers or
click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep it a date with the channel
so hopefully we see over there very soon
but if not then I tell you what you can
do one I'm sick ear know I love you take
care goodbye peace
[Music]
[Music]